welcome back so we're talking about data
science this is an intro overview
lecture series on kind of what is data
science how can you use it what are the
aspects and one thing I think is just
really important to emphasize is the
data science is not new we've been doing
data science as humans for hundreds
thousands of years collecting data
modeling the world through that data and
I think data science as a terminology
means different things to different
people so there's what I like to think
of as data intensive science data
intensive engineering or data-driven
inquiry and that's science that you do
based on data ok like if I want to solve
so astronomy is a great example of
something that is data intensive science
I think of the phrase data science this
is an emerging scientific discipline
which is motivated by data intensive
science but it's really the science of
how do you handle data collect clean
store visualize and model with data so
it's a little confusing you have data
driven science and that motivates this
whole new field of science and
engineering called data science and I'm
going to use them interchangeably but
that I just want to kind of deconflict
those two terms early on and astronomy
is a great example I want to walk you
through just this very interesting
history example that I loved about kind
of Tycho Brahe and Kepler and Newton to
give some idea of what data science
looks like in a historical context so
this is Tycho Brahe great Danish
astronomer who collected the rich data
set of the motion of planets and stars
that was critical in Kepler's discovery
of his his ellipses and planetary motion
so to some extent Tycho Brahe was
noticed inconsistencies between the
models of the time kind of the the old
law
of how the planets would move and he
noticed inconsistencies with what he
observed so you know he there was this
predicted conjunction of planets and it
didn't agree with the models to his
satisfaction and so he realized this I
think was as a teenager that he needed
to collect rigorous clean data to store
it in a systematic format and to to make
a science out of the data collection of
planets and stars and he dedicated his
life to this he had an island between
Copenhagen and Sweden I don't know if
you can see it here but this is his
science island of hven where he
collected all of this rich data and he
guarded this data so this was his life's
work and he knew how much value and it
turns out Kepler didn't even really have
full access to the data until Tico Bray
passed away and so so both of the knew
the value of the data and kind of moving
moving the theory of planetary motion
forward and this was a critical piece in
Kepler's famous law of the elliptic
planets elliptic motion of planets fun
fact about Tico very interesting
character I encourage you to read more
about him he lost the tip of his nose in
a duel when he was a young man arguing
about who was a better mathematician on
his Science Island he had a pet moose
which was apparently very fond of beer
and would entertain his guests by
drinking a tremendous amount of beer so
Chico Bray is a really interesting guy
you can only imagine what his
personality would be like he had to you
know he made his life's work of very
very very careful observations which
changed the world forever through
through those who came after and I think
this also laid the foundation so this
this data intensive inquiry laid the
foundation for what Newton would go on
to do so
Kepler described these elliptic motion
of the planets and Newton explained why
the plants move in these ellipses and
actually I think a great
quote by Isaac Newton's Newton when he
was explaining one of his theories he
said that it was because of a
preponderance of the evidence and that's
another way of saying the data supported
his hypothesis or his theory and
something else I think is really
fascinating that we should think about
as data scientists and modelers and
machine learning people today and this
is something I talk a lot about with my
colleague Nathan Cutts is this idea of
the difference between Kepler and Newton
so Kepler built a model of how things
work the way they work on these
elliptical planets this is kind of I
think of an attractor of how how the
world and how the the solar system works
in these elliptical orbits that theory
was useful but it wouldn't have allowed
us to to develop the Apollo program and
and put people on the moon okay and so
what Newton did was somehow a
generalization he distilled the abstract
physical principle that gave rise to
elliptic orbits but in a way that you
could tell you what would happen if you
left your elliptical orbit so what would
happen if you left or pushed on the
system out of the way that it always
behaves and we've always observed it and
his theory truly generalized F equals MA
generalized in a way that allowed us to
land people on the moon which is which
is really a huge achievement and so we
talk about this a lot a lot of machine
learning algorithms today most of them I
would say do what Kepler did they
describe the world as we observe it as
the data describes it and it takes this
epiphany this great leap to get a model
that truly generalizes like what Newton
did and so we should be aspiring to make
our algorithms go
you know from Kepler to Newton and that
that's a worthwhile goal it's also very
very challenging okay so data science
has been around for a long time there's
a really interesting modern book called
the fourth paradigm data-intensive
scientific discovery which basically
shows or describes this progression from
kind of theory and analytics
Mattox to experiments collecting data
from you know running experiments to
test hypotheses to simulations and
numerix and computations kind of the the
digital you know silicon age and now
this fourth paradigm of data-driven
inquiry and scientific discovery really
interesting and you know how this
complements this doesn't this doesn't
displace theory or numerix or
experiments it complements these
generate massive amounts of data and we
need a science that ties these together
okay just like simulations didn't
displace experiments they complement
each other okay so that's just a very
high-level overview I will point out for
those of you who are kind of more
interested in the nuts and bolts of
machine learning and modeling and kind
of the linear algebra and optimization
underlying these data science algorithms
I'll recommend a book that my colleague
Nathan cuts and I just wrote data-driven
science and engineering in Cambridge and
we have a website data book u-dub com
where we filmed up all of our lectures
for all of the chapters and sections so
for example you can go to our website
and find you know different topics
you're interested in and see our YouTube
videos so if you're interested hopefully
that's a resource to kind of get into
the more nitty gritty mathematical
aspects okay thank you